SHE WAS IN THE BATHROOM AT THE
TIME AND SHE RAN FROM HIM AND
GOT TO HER ROOM SHE FOUND OPEN.
IT'S THE ONE HORRIFIC SCENE.
JOINING US NOW, THE OTHER
SENATOR FROM FLORIDA, DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR BILL NELSON.
SENATOR, I'VE HEARD YOU REACT
TODAY BUT YOU LISTEN TO THOSE
STUDENTS ARE YOUR THOUGHTS AS
YOU ARE GETTING THE NUMBER OF
FATALITIES FROM AUTHORITIES.
>> WHEN I WAS ON YOUR COLLEAGUES
SHOW, SHEPARD SMITH, EARLIER
THIS AFTERNOON, I KNEW IT WAS
MANY FATALITIES.
I DIDN'T WANT TO JUMP THE GUN
AND SAID "A NUMBER OF
FATALITIES."
AS YOU START TO CONFIRM THE
NUMBER, IT COMES AND OUR WORST
FEARS ARE REALIZED.
OF COURSE YOU GRIEVE.
YOU JUST THINK HOW THERE'S
PARENTS WHO ARE GRIEVING, THE
SCHOOL OFFICIALS AND MAYBE A
SCHOOLTEACHER AMONG THOSE
FATALITIES.
YOU CAN IMAGINE WHAT THEY ARE
GOING THROUGH.
MY THOUGHTS AND, I'VE ALREADY
PRAYED FOR COMFORT FOR ALL OF
OUR PEOPLE DOWN IN
BROWARD COUNTY.
>> Bret: LISTENING TO THE
SCHOOLS SUPERINTENDENT, SENATOR,
THIS WAS A JOYOUS DAY.
THEY WERE CELEBRATING TEACHER OF
THE YEAR IN BROWARD COUNTY.
SHE GOT A NEW CAR.
AND THEN HE WAS DRIVING GOT WORD
OF THIS SHOOTING.
I UNDERSTAND IT'S THE BIGGEST
SHOOTING IN BROWARD COUNTY'S
HISTORY AND NOW WITH THIS
FATALITY, IT WILL LIKELY BE ONE
OF THE BIGGEST IN THE NATION.
>> REMEMBER IT WAS JUST A YEAR
AGO THAT WE HAD THE SHOOTING IN
THE FORT LAUDERDALE AIRPORT, THE
VERY SAME COUNTY.
REMEMBER IT WAS JUST A FEW
MONTHS AGO THE MASS SHOOTING IN
LAS VEGAS.
YOU CAN GO ALL THE WAY BACK TO
SANDY HOOK AND BEYOND THAT.
BACK TO COLUMBINE.
BRET, WHAT DOES IT TAKE FOR US
TO COME TO OUR SENSES AS A
CIVILIZED AND LOVING PEOPLE TO
STOP THIS MASS MURDER?
>> Bret: I GUESS IT'S A
QUESTION, YOU KNOW, THE POLITICS
OF THIS AND FIGHTING ABOUT HOW
TO GET TO A SOLUTION.
ON THIS DAY, IT'S TOUGH TO SEE
HOW YOU CAN STOP IT AS IT IS
NOW.
IS IT THE ACCESS TO GUNS?
IS IT THE MENTAL HEALTH ASPECT
OF THINGS?
WE DON'T KNOW THE ANSWERS TO
WHAT MOTIVATED THIS KID.
DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING FROM
AUTHORITIES ABOUT THE SUSPECT
AND WHAT WAS BEHIND IT?
>> NO, AND OF COURSE THE
INVESTIGATION WILL BRING ALL OF
THAT OUT.
BUT YOU HAVE ASKED THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS.
WAS IT LEGAL TO PURCHASE IT?
WAS IT A HIGH-CAPACITY CALIBER
WEAPON?
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITION?
ALL OF THE ABOVE ARE THINGS THAT
OUGHT TO BE EXAMINED AND OUGHT
TO BE, TRIED TO BE DEALT WITH IN
THE FUTURE.
>> Bret: IN THE CURRENT
ENVIRONMENT, IS IT GOING TO
HAPPEN?
>> WELL, WHEN YOU CONSIDER, AS I
SHARED WITH SHEPARD SMITH
EARLIER, WHEN YOU CONSIDER THAT
DIANNE FEINSTEIN HAD A BILL THAT
WE VOTED ON THAT WAS SIMPLY TO
TAKE THE TERRORIST WATCH LIST OF
TERRORISTS AND PUT A PROHIBITION
THAT THEY COULD NOT BUY A GUN
AND THAT WAS DEFEATED.
I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION, BRET.
>> Bret: WE ARE WAITING ON
AUTHORITIES.
OBVIOUSLY THEY HAVE THEIR HANDS
FULL TRYING TO PIECE ALL OF THIS
TOGETHER BUT THIS IS A MASSIVE
UNDERTAKING FOR THE
BROWARD COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT.
>> IF THOSE NUMBERS END UP LIKE
IS BEING SPECULATED ON THE
NUMBER OF FATALITIES, THEN
INDEED THIS IS ONE OF THE WORST
CRIMES AND TRAGEDIES THAT
FLORIDA HAS EVER SEEN.
ONE DEATH IS TOO MANY.
THIS MAY BE MULTIPLE.
>> Bret: SENATOR, WE